all right president biden is also
expected to visit louisiana tomorrow to
survey ida's catastrophic impact there
we've been telling you hundreds of
thousands of people are still without
power and many cannot get food water or
fuel or marvia franca is in kenner
louisiana omar good morning
good morning vlad more generators are
being brought in so we're starting to
see some lights pop up across the city
that's going to be really helpful when
you're trying to clean up damage like
this at this warehouse the governor says
there are more line workers in the state
than at any other point in history but
for the hundreds of thousands of people
who are still without power
things can't move fast enough
four days without power and new orleans
is starting to boil
it's hot and tempers are fraying long
lines for military rations ice and fresh
water
miss ebony joel simmons says she walks
10 miles just to fill her cart with
supplies i woke up this morning i got me
a pillow and a blanket and i said i'm
gonna go down there and sleep if i have
to there has been some progress
[Music]
power was restored for more than 11
thousand people in east new orleans
it was a blessing you know but many are
still in the dark and if it's not by
morning i'm leaving without water and
power the frustration is growing but
here on grand isle the residents who
live here haven't even had a chance to
see what's left of their island and for
most of those 1400 residents there is
not much to come back to
homes were blown apart by ida's
ferocious winds
power lines snapped and twisted
seven miles of barrier island stripped
of life-sustaining infrastructure we
surveyed the destruction with mayor
david cammerdale 100 of the buildings
the homes and the businesses
major damage
85 percent is total 85 85 to 95 percent
is total we have no food
we have no water we shut the gas off and
we have no electricity i would never
thought
i'm sorry
i mean you got you got time here you got
memories here yeah
those who stayed behind have started to
rebuild and supplies are starting to
arrive
but while the road to recovery will be
long camerdale is determined to bring
grand isle back better than ever we're
born and raised here this is paradise
you know long as there's one grain of
sand in grand isle i'm gonna plant the
american flag i can promise you that
at last check nearly 3 000 people were
staying in about 30 shelters across the
state and in the age of kovid
that is a concern
gail we feel for that man thank you very
much omar